in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape joining me in
the studio is Professor toston Bauer
lung specialist from the Helios clinic
email phone bearing here in Berlin I
compressor dalu the show hi it's pretty
alarming that those last resort drugs
are used more often and often so it does
it mean we are turning back to the
medieval times where we don't have any
biotics available at our hands nor don't
think so resistance of microorganisms is
a natural phenomenon when we introduced
penicillin for example in the early 50s
we had the first resistant
microorganisms in the 60s so we have to
deal with it yeah and the materials are
dealing with that as well on their side
yeah story they have their chance jens
so how big is the problem of Marji
resistant drugs quality is a big big
problem all over the world especially
when it comes to tuberculosis there are
different rules and tuberculosis but
within our hospitals we do have multi
drug-resistant infections and can you
say how many people die from mud
resistant bacterias worldwide it's it's
very difficult to say except for
tuberculosis because patients who
require multidrug-resistant
microorganisms in the hospital usually
have another problem whether they die
from this infection is difficult to say
but it a couple of thousands every year
and if you look worldwide are those
germs found all over the world and are
they equally distributed no definitely
not tuberculosis is not equally
distributed over the world and we do
have multi drug-resistant organisms in
the hospital in the very developed
countries hi developed medicine we do
have these problems in some countries
even if they do have high developed
medicine have lower rates of
multi-resistant germs so what are they
doing right there's always a problem of
the hygiene when you have for example in
Holland inand Dutch countries they do
have a very low incidence of mrs
multi drug-resistant staph aureus in
their hospitals and they they have
limited access to their intensive care
units and they take time to see whether
the patient is colonized with this
organism is that what you mean they have
limited access to their intensive care
units they surely put patients into ICU
if they needed to be there yeah but when
when you come off the road for example
with an accident and you need to have
accessed eleven o'clock at night they
put you in a special room they take that
time to see whether you have super bugs
on you and when that's negative you go
to the intensive care and if you caught
something like a super back can you get
ever rid of it yeah the immune system
usually paralyzes these microorganisms
very fast for example doctors are
probably colonized with those
microorganisms but never get sick
because of the good work of the immune
system and you already told us about
tuberculosis but there are certainly
other diseases which you can get with
multi-resistant bacterias and what what
kind of diseases are there well number
one is nosocomial pneumonia so the lung
infection you get when when you
mechanically ventilated on the intensive
care unit hmmm and what about wounds and
and stuff like skin infections skin
infections are a problem always when
when blood doesn't get to the to the
site of infection like for example if
you have diabetes and your vessels are
very small and you don't have a high
blood flow in this area you get multi
drug-resistant infections they're
visible what do you think is plasma the
next new big thing in medicine well it's
a fascinating method it's it is a answer
but not the answer to soft tissue
infections and it's just used for a
superficial disinfection or well
superficial disinfection is not a
problem if you have an antibiotic
surface like a table you can disinfect
it it is always when you have a wound
infection the question how Fargo's it
into the tissue and this is also the
question you have to tell a turtle to
ask to the plasma researchers so what
other methods are available in treating
for instance wounds with multi-resistant
bacteria well they are fascinating
methods around for example also bacteria
can get diseases for example there are a
couple
viruses that kill bacteria so far we do
have some results with these infections
of bacteria but it's very hard to
control so you're putting infectious
virus onto bacteria and hope that they
fight it off they do but they usually
also fight human cells off so the answer
is not exactly that what you want to
have okay we got a view question rubbed
Roy from India asked whether antibiotic
resistant bacteria can killed by UV
light or LED light or simply by boiling
water yeah there's absolutely no
difference in there and the killing
techniques for bacteria whether they're
drug resistant or not usually hot water
is the perfect physical method to
destroy bacteria no matter whether
they're resistant to antibiotics or not
how much do you have to worry is a
healthy person really likely to get some
multi-resistant bacterias from just
eating meat well if you don't cook it
you you will get this micro organisms
but you'll probably not even get sick
when you're a healthy person and and the
bacteria count is not high so it's
usually it safe if you cook it and if
you wash your hands yeah what she showed
that she washed the meat so she reduces
the number of bacteria on the meat but
what you should never do is you should
never prepare a polo tree on a wooden
plate and have to sell it afterwards on
it because then the cell that has the
multi drug-resistant organisms are
contaminated and gets all the germs and
what about all those antibacterial
dishwashing liquids and hence helps you
got a view question about this our
viewers thank him Tim May from Cambodia
asked if they could perhaps contribute
to the problem they do they do they go
down the drain they they get diluted and
I and I don't have the killing effect
anymore and I introduce antibiotic
resistance or resistance at all so I
don't recommend to get to put anti
desinfect ins into the soap ok so so you
don't even worry it's not open they're
not as a doctor but bet for normal
people you don't have to wash your hands
with alcoholic solutions no okay we've
got a view question from your way maria
brink Oh says her doctor prescribed
penicillin for a throat infection but it
didn't work she asked if she herself is
resistant to penicillin
no no there's always the microorganism
that gets sore develops resistance in
this special case probably the throat
infection was a viral infection that's
why penicillin didn't help which doesn't
mean it doesn't help the next time but
can you as a patient do something
against developing multi-resistant germs
yeah you have to be critical and using
antibiotics if the doctor prescribes
antibiotics you have to take them for a
certain time and you shouldn't repeat
these the same antibiotic within a time
frame of about 30 days so always stick
to what your doctor says there well I
hope helps sometimes so and what do you
personally do to not catch any
multi-resistant germs well I am the
doctor walked daily in a daily routine
in the hospital we disinfect our hands
after each contact with the patient and
I wash my hands before I go home that
was enough for the last 20 years there
was a power thanks so much for being
with us thank you thank you so much
you